have you seen the stat michael that the
chargers yes
have lost 13 games in the last two years
one score by one yeah it's crazy one
score
and here's the other one so the saints
last night they trailed by as many as 17
of course
14 to overcome a 17 point deficit on
monday night football
since 2010. three out of those four have
come against the chargers
i mean we talked about the falcons i
mean
they're like cousins that live across
country from each other all that
said though if i am a charger fan
then my voice would high if i'm a
charger if i'm a charger fan
right now you can't tell me nothing
because we got a guy we got a guy at
quarterback
and i would much rather be one in four
not finishing games
than be three and two
not knowing where my franchise starts
and ends
like they know they got a a a potential
star
starting quarterback we know how many
times that the chargers couldn't get
over the hump with philip rivers one of
my favorite quarterbacks in a recent
member
couldn't get over the help with philip
rivers right you know always seem to
under achieve and if they got to the
playoffs they only went so far
and you know a lot of times man teams
aren't fortunate enough to get
another stuff
this guy is a problem he's good okay he
has gone toe-to-toe with my homes
whatever's left of brady and breeze and
i'll played all of them
how is he the first rookie quarterback
to throw four touchdown passes on monday
night football
that's incredible that he's the first
guy to do that as a rookie right
unbelievable all right he's something
before we get but before we get to him
before we get to him you just said
something you said hey if i'm a chargers
fan
i'm excited you're feeling good i don't
care about this i don't care about the
law
i feel like okay you you uh you're
bristled that's that's a
that's the right way of putting you
pushed back when i said that the falcons
were cursed remember i said i said
they're cursed
you're like no that's not courage that's
not a curse i'll give you all these
examples
why the falcons occur some franchises
are cursed
they are okay with the falcon above with
the charges though i don't know if it's
cursed
it's something between the ears though i
don't know if they need
life coaches or or a different coach
i don't know but when you lose that many
close games mike
and you have the talent that they've had
it's not just the last two years great
step for the last two years
but i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna ask you
this and you won't be able to answer
what's the definitive what's a
definitive game
in chargers history is it like that that
time sorry rodney harrison
that time they went to the super bowl
and got done by by the niners and steve
young's nine it was it was probably the
afc title game
that year but yeah i gotcha i
mean like here's the only thing i would
say to you something's in the dirt man
it's in the dirt
whether it's san diego or los angeles
okay
here's the only thing i would say to you
about this whole curse thing
all right is that or just low
expectations you're cursed
but you're cursed until you're not you
curse until you're not
you're you're coming to me live from
boston you're coming to me live from
boston
so you're cursed and then they they
break the curse so is it a curse you
could break it
no it wasn't cursed it wasn't a curse no
it wasn't
it wasn't common it was incompetence or
it was it was penance for being the last
team to integrate
who knows whatever it was and racism and
racism
yeah they're racist
yeah you know yeah okay so there you go
so okay you're talking to somebody who
grew up in new orleans
where they wore bags on their heads to
saints games they
ain't they weren't cursed they were the
saints they weren't
cursed they were the opposite of curse
they were blessed well
and eventually they won the super bowl
and now if anything i think that los
angeles got it out before because all
these
awful calls so i don't think the los
angeles chargers they need like a whole
some whole session just like a whole
they need a makeover
because you look at them when they they
take that lead
a busted play by the saints and it's too
bad you know
in a pandemic it's more obvious you know
you're there in the superdome
who is it patrick robinson who is that
the corner who gave up the big play so
patrick robinson they're in the super in
an empty superdome
you give up a 64-yard touchdown
it's all your fault it's all your fault
you're sitting down in the zone you're
waiting for help that ain't coming
and so the cameras are there and like
you can't even pretend like they can't
nobody else is there you can't pretend
like you don't see the cameras here
and the cameras just held there for a
long they were just on them for a long
time i kind of felt bad for the brother
you know
just sitting there trying to drink some
gatorade you know that's like one of
those things when the camera's on you
you're just acting like you're drinking
something
it just i'm just just gonna distract
myself until you go away but they never
went away
so in that situation 27 20 about four
minutes left in the game
you should win that game i mean you
should win it you make a stop
you make a stop which they didn't play
some ball control
and you win it have your kicker make a
field goal which it didn't
so i mean i think part of it is it's
just you just
expect bad things it's not a curse
you're right yes but you get to it
but it doesn't matter it defies
explanations
how does this keep happening but it
doesn't it doesn't divide okay
you get to the point as an organization
and as a fan base where you expect
bad things to happen and i think that's
just it just infects
it affects a team a building a region
somebody comes in and changing
somebody's gotta come in i talked about
boston
i thought and i like anthony lynn a lot
but i talked about boston
what were the patriots with the
exception in 1985 what were the patriots
throughout their history
they called laughing stock for the most
part exactly yeah so parcells comes
along and establishes credibility and
then it's parcells and pete carroll and
even there was a circus with that
even he created a circus it was even a
certain joke
you know what he thought all i know is
but all i know is
all i know is i will ex if i'm a charger
fan i woke up this morning
thinking about four touchdowns not one
in four
i woke up thinking about the fact that
yo that guy is
good and that we haven't seen tua play
yet
i mean after week one or two i mean
burrows
i'm punching i'm driving bird of the
hall of fame
i'm bringing burro i'm like you going
right up the road to canton you going
from cincinnati drive
right like it's a short try you know
exactly and now like hold
on this this this might be uh
the best guy this draft might be in l.a
fall i know this well you know what
it's funny that you say that performance
you said it because our uh our brother
from another uh chris sims came on here
last week remember we were talking about
herbert he said or two weeks ago he said
herbert was his number one guy when he
was doing his
his pre-draft analysis arm talents he's
got a lot he liked him
he liked herbert was his number one
quarterback over
everybody else but you think about these
quarterbacks i'm with you he looks he
just looks
good he looks like he belongs he's not
friend he's not uh
he's not frazzled the moment's not too
big from all that stuff is true
you can say that about some players but
for him it's just obvious he's got he's
got what it takes
but if you look at all these young
quarterbacks in the league
doesn't it seem like just a few years
ago we were wondering okay
where are the quarterbacks where are the
young talented quarterbacks
the obvious ones are patrick mahomes you
mentioned him lamar jackson deshawn
watson but now you throw in herbert you
throw in
burrow you've got some guys and some
guys in
in college who don't know what they're
going to turn out to be but they're well
regarded highly regarded
i hear people talking about trevor
lawrence like he's a generational
prospect he's in the same category as
elway yeah same category as andrew luck
so we've got some young quarterbacks who
are really making a push
to make a a stamp on this league
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports